screening for lung cancer means looking
for signs of cancer in your lungs before
you have symptoms screening can help
find cancer at an early stage this can
make treating it easier because the
cancer might not have spread
screening for lung cancer is recommended
once a year if you have a 20-pack year
history of smoking cigarettes meaning
you have smoked about a pack a day for
20 years
or two packs a day for 10 years smoke
now or have quit smoking within the past
15 years
and are between 50 and 80 years old you
may stop yearly screening for lung
cancer if you are over 81 years old
haven't smoked in 15 or more years
or have a health problem that makes you
unable or unwilling to have surgery if
lung cancer is found
the only recommended screening test for
lung cancer is low-dose computed
tomography this is also known as a
low-dose CT scan or ldct
an ldct machine emits a very low dose of
x-rays that makes a series of detailed
pictures of your lungs from different
angles a computer uses the pictures to
make a 3D view of your lungs to look for
signs of cancer if abnormal tissue is
found you may need to have other tests
or procedures
if you are at high risk for developing
lung cancer getting a low-dose CT scan
could save your life
but getting the scan also has three
potential risks first it may give a
false positive result this means the
test result says you have cancer when
you don't really have it
second it may lead to over-diagnosis
this means the test has found a type of
cancer that isn't likely to cause you
any problems both a false positive
result and over diagnosis can lead to
other tests or procedures that you don't
need and may have their own risks and
third there is a very low risk that
getting many CT scans May expose
otherwise healthy people to enough
x-rays that could cause cancer
this is why screening is only
recommended for those at high risk for
having lung cancer
if you have questions about this test or
your test results talk to your
Healthcare practitioner